la frc a le département de la réunion le
syndicat du sucre de la réunion nous
présente terre d'ici
pour
miel vert ces boeufs ses moutons c'est
cabris et ses produits péi installé dans
sa cuisine au coeur du gymnase marie
thérèse en tout près par son premier
plat du manioc façon grand-mère qu'elle
ait jamais les manieurs j'ai mis le lot
gérer rajouter le climat oui je devais
mettre un peu le poivre d'accord et ne
pas oublier votre graisse de canard et
comme je disais ce matin davantage de la
graisse de canard
c'est très bon pour les gens qui
comptent ducos cholestérol
il y est pareil l'on peut faire un plein
de recettes
après c'est comme tout et tout produit
break grand jour et la libération
peinture et la crise de tana c'est un
très bon produit pour la santé mais avec
modération
la graisse de canard on peut commander
ici dans notre caverne d'ali baba comme
je le dis tous les jours pleins de
produits péi de la vie bien assaisonnée
à la graisse de canard et aux épices
pays le manioc va cuire ainsi pendant
une bonne heure en attendant marie
thérèse s'activent à la préparation
d'une deuxième recette tout aussi
savoureuse et faciles à réaliser des
béni de papaye verte à la morue c'est ma
chère pourquoi c'est pas cher parce
qu'on va récupérer la papaye chez son
voisin ou même si on l'achète au marché
forain avec un sachet de
de farine un petit sachet de levure on
peut faire à manger une centaine de
personnes 1 et ça pas vraiment un coin
portant juste l'amo et voilà la morue
qui est un produit très cher maintenant
la réunion mais on peut faire avec plein
d'autres choses
et pour réussir ces beignets marie
thérèse nous révèle aussi ses petits
secrets
quand on fait un bélier il faut qu'il y
ait un grand bain d'huile droit pour que
les beignets rôle de dan de rien mais ne
prennent pas
après toujours laisser égoutter mathurin
sopalin de son qu'on fait à l'ancien
maire qui n'ait pas droit produits moi
j'ai plus occasion de faire les plats
traditionnels pour ça je découvre un peu
les produits je trouve que c'est le
meilleur baigner qu'on a préparé depuis
l' aventure avec l'association goûte à
nous avec mes vinet madame en tout c'est
le meilleur lamoureux elle est bien
répartie à l'intérieur du beignet c'est
ça qui est le rehausse le goût le goût
des bons produits authentiques que les
visiteurs de miel vert ont pu ce jour-là
déguster et apprécier avec plaisir je
mangeais kim baigner mourut avec 2
manioc et ben je trouve ça excellent et
moi japonais kohei découvre la panière
super super est ce que c'est bon vous
riez dans les tribunes fait du riz pour
nadal en demies
épaulé par ses deux filles marie thérèse
en tout a repris aujourd'hui les rênes
de l'association goutta nous créé par
feu christian son mari cuisinière de
talent elle poursuit désormais avec
succès la même mission celle de défendre
et de promouvoir la cuisine réunionnaise
traditionnels au départ on avait un peu
peur on dit est ce qu'on sera capable
est ce qu'on sera à la hauteur
et c'est vrai qu'on était tous les jours
avec lui ou se poser la question mais
quand on voit la science satisfaction
des gens eh ben je dis oui nous on a
notre place a continué à défendre ce
patrimoine
quand je vois ces gens qui
m'applaudissent qui me dit continue ma
mentaux et ben je dis c'est presque
gagné en partenariat avec l'association
produits pays réunion les chefs de gouda
nous ont concocté durant toute la durée
de miel vert de boukari de la cuisine
réunionnaise
ce matin là mes vignes dans gaza me
s'active à préparer un carré de boucane
et à la banane verte plein plutôt plutôt
rensin lui plutôt rats et c'est ça qu'on
le fait que tout le monde
voit-on peut cuisiner avec les produits
longtemps belle nova fait quand même
bouquin et bringel sauf à la place d'un
gel on va mettre la banane rillettes la
banane verte ont trouvé souvent dans les
jardins chez nous les personnes pauvres
et donc qu'on va faire goûter aux jeunes
les plats longtemps pour éviter les la
malbouffe en fait après avoir fait
revenir le boucané avec des oignons on
rajoute ensuite les autres épices là on
va mettre un petit peu d'ail
les oignons pris un peu de couleurs
voilà
un créole long terme être joués pédaillé
peu de gens mais géniaux pour aussi
donne toujours du goût
on va baisser la température mais bien
pour laisser compoter la voit la passe à
8 pour que la tomate compote avec le
curcuma pour que ça donne beaucoup
d'arômes et on va rajouter nos banane
après quand la tomate a bien cru
maintenant on va rajouter les bananes
banane vite qu on a pré cuits à la
vapeur et là haut on les a plus chez on
les a coupés en petits morceaux et là on
en rajoute dans le book année là on a
mis de la banane on va pas mettre
beaucoup de riz à côté on va mettre une
cuillère rit parce que la banane c'est
un féculent et avec une bonne salade à
côté etc et c'est bien et c'est bien le
goût des le goût de banane
la recette se trouve sur le site
internet
gotham au point est revenu comme moi
pour toute l'équipe de l'association
good and we midi
et pour les visiteurs et lily
tha
donc